an arts district staple is closing its
doors for reasons you may not think
martin's mart thrift shop on main street
near charleston has actually been a part
of that las vegas community since the
80s but madison kimbrough explains why
volunteers are now heartbroken over the
fact that they aren't going to be able
to stay open much longer madison
i've covered several stories in this
area many of which have to deal with the
expansion of the arts district but here
at martin's mart thrift shop as you can
see they are having to close their doors
due to high rent prices and lack of
support
it just like breaks my heart to see
something that's a legend that's been in
the same area
for 53 years and having to shut doors
for good martin's mart will be closing
its doors in november the volunteered
base thrift store is struggling to pay
rent originally paying just under a
thousand dollars it's now increased to
almost two thousand volunteer judy shock
says recently adding paid parking has
deterred shoppers and finding staff to
operate it is tough too we would like to
keep open
but i think the biggest thing that we
have no control over
and that is volunteers
you can't make someone volunteer many
former volunteers who grew up going to
the shop now have had to take a step
back after the pandemic having to
provide a steady income for themselves
and not being able to volunteer their
time like miles hoffman at 15 years old
i would ride my bike around the area and
i came up here i want to do whatever i
can to help save it move it what have
you whatever we can do you know it's a
vital resource i feel and in recent
months the city of las vegas announced
plans on expanding the arts district
area which for many store owners and
locals fear will mean higher rent and
the closure of more stores i'm afraid
that if it continues this isn't going to
be the the arts district that was built
on i think it's like trying to push out
the
little guys like this that kind of give
the neighborhood character
a gofundme has been created to help
martin's mart with rent fees in hopes
that they won't have to close down as of
now they are open three days a week and
we'll have a link to that gofundme page
up on our website at 8newsnow.com
reporting live in the arts district
madison kimbrough 8 news now